glenn younkin's victory last month
showed that schools are one of the top
issues for voters parents have had
enough of the totally unjustified school
closures and the ideological
brainwashing all of it driven by the
teacher unions and they're demanding
change
well the biggest change of all could be
on its way in of all places my home
state of california thanks to a new
cross-party movement led by our next
guests who are aiming to put the biggest
and boldest school choice initiative
america has ever seen on the ballot in
2022 i'm absolutely delighted to welcome
someone you all know well as former
acting director of national intelligence
rick grinnell but he's also the founder
of fix california and gloria romero who
was previously the democrat majority
leader in the california state senate
and along with rick is co-chair of the
fixed california initiative for school
choice funding all right rick um great
to see you great to see you too gloria
rick you kick us off what have you got
planned for next year
well first of all i'm ecstatic to be
able to co-chair this with gloria romero
i mean the glory is somebody who's a
champion
a proud democrat somebody who really
understands california together
we've decided that it's unacceptable
to have the kids of wealthy parents rich
parents
be the only ones who get to pick their
school
right now we have a whole bunch of kids
who have to go to the crappy school down
the street
and america is about competition and so
what we're doing is putting a ballot
initiative to the vote of the people
next year in the 2022 elections in
california asking californians do you
want to upend the way we fund education
and have the money follow the student we
think it's about time
it's absolutely thrilling because it's
real school choice in a big way it's not
just a few kind of charter schools here
or there it's the whole system changing
gloria i'm so happy to welcome you and
um i'd just love to to know first of all
what what what was it that persuaded you
to team up with rick um behind this
great initiative
well first of all i have the greatest
regard and respect for rick but but
education is my passion when i was in
the california state senate i oversaw
education chairing the education
committee and i saw firsthand how
california spends almost half of our
budget every year to fund a system not
students but a system that consistently
fails students and their families so
this initiative says no more funding a
black hole of education we are going to
fund directly parents students so
parents can choose the best school
choice for them that's my commitment
so i've got to ask you gloria i mean i'm
i'm all for it i've long argued for it
the teacher unions of course are dead
against it because it takes the power
away from them and puts it in the hands
of the parents
most democrats
are completely kind of you know bowed
down before the teacher unions you've
taken us taken this stand
why is that and how's that been for you
personally
well undoubtedly the california teachers
association is the
most powerful political force in
california more powerful than oil
tobacco pharmaceutical companies it is
the single it has the single biggest war
chest to really scare sacramento
legislators away from doing the right
thing so that's why this initiative is
really so important but as you pointed
out as we started talking we've seen
parents in action parents are basically
saying ya vasa enough we're tired we
want to put our kids first and so that's
why we believe that education savings
account will really register with
parents to give us true school choice
yeah because it's taking all of the
money that the state spends
if this goes through and and and all of
it you know not just a little bit all of
it and then the parents get to decide
rick um and this will have national
implications
can people watching who don't live in
california can they support this how i
mean to talk about the national aspect
of this because it's a really big
big change that you're proposing
i think you're right steve i mean if
california is going to do this this is
really going to go into every single
state california used to be the state
where we'd try things first but over the
last decades we've been doing everything
last and so what i would say to people
across this country is if you really
believe in upending the whole system
let's bet on parents let's bet on the
fact that parents want to send their
kids to the best school and they're
going to select their best school for
them and so everyone should go to
fixcalifornia.com
sign up to help us give us a little bit
of money what we need to be able to do
is demonstrate to the rest of the
country that parents after a year and a
half of zoom school
want to have the power to pick the
school for their kids let's let the
parents do let's trust the parents and
let's give them the tools that they need
let's not have just the wealthy kids
going to private schools or being able
to pick look some people are going to
pick the public schools if they have a
really good public school that's great
but let's give the power to the parents
not just to the rich parents
it is such an inspiring message so cool
so fantastic that both of you um have
come together to to try and make this
happen rick and gloria really appreciate
it totally echo what you said rick
everyone should go to
fixcalifornia.com and see how they can
help
great to see you both thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else